Timothy Spall is an actor with the
filmography that encompasses everything
from the cornerstones of Western
literature to the most modern mind
pieces in contemporary cinema and is
studded with awards and accolades of
every kind here are a few of the films
you might have seen him in spall might
play a different character in a very
different setting in Tim Burton's
adaptation of Sweeney Todd
but Potterheads will likely notice more
than a few similarities with Peter
Pettigrew his character Edel Bamford is
a wretched gleeful servant of Alan
Rickman's sinister Judge Turpin a man
whose power he clings to in the hopes
that some might rub off on him he is
deeply duplicitous luring innocents into
terpenes path through carefully deployed
secrets and lies
skimming whatever he can off the top
whenever he can get away with it and
he's not even the villain of this story
so much as he is a pitiful also-ran with
delusions of grandeur Beadle Bamford be
the judge as always my friends and
neighbors above all of these
similarities to Pettigrew however is the
sheer quality of Spall's performance no
one could have been as perfectly servile
as he is in his role nor so sumptuously
aware of his characters impotence spall
plays Bamford like a man who thinks he's
on the up and up with an actor's
awareness of the fact that he definitely
isn't as Winston Churchill in the King's
Speech small plays a larger-than-life
role yet in the context of this movie
it's not exactly a starring line spall
is instead a supporting player to Colin
Firth as King George the sixth in his
portrayal of the Kings
struggle to master his persistent
stammer as the movie winds on tensions
across Europe begin to brew and Spall's
Churchill finds himself unable to make
the declaration of war against Nazi
Germany by himself that is a duty that
falls to the king and the king alone and
so the training begins to take the King
from his impenetrable stutter to smooth
confident recitation the presence of
Spall's Churchill is a grounding force
in the film's final scenes in which King
George the sixth accomplishes his goal
and changes the world with nothing but
the power of his voice a microphone and
radio
broadcasting a rollicking ruthless
portrayal of arts and what fuels it the
critically acclaimed biopic mr Turner
sees small play the painter JMW Turner
accounts at the time depicted Turner as
consciously refusing the trappings of
Fame tying himself to ship's masts to
better paint sea scenes and never quite
fitting in with his colleagues at the
royal academy of art but his work was
utterly sublime capturing the power and
violence of nature as readily as its
Grace and tranquillity he was a deeply
complicated figure and small fills the
role like no one else would in a way the
actor takes to the role as Turner
himself took the painting passionately
and skillfully you've always been
preoccupied you're too preoccupied for
your own good sir spawn plays another
villainous henchman in Disney's
Enchanted the film sees Giselle a
woodland princess from the magical land
of andalasia trapped in New York City
when the Wicked Queen Nerissa pushes her
into a dimension spanning portal
Nerissa sends forth her helplessly
lovesick minion Nathaniel to keep an eye
on Giselle and generally do her bidding
spall gets to be quite a bit funnier
here than as peter pettigrew or beetle
Bamford and unlike with those other
characters ultimately gets to find his
Redemption our last glimpse of Nathaniel
and Enchanted finds him promoting a
self-help book about his experiences
with a long and ardent line of autograph
seekers waiting to meet him here spall
proves that not all of the servile
wretches need to be totally loathesome
he can make you root for them to unique
among these entries the BBC series
Timothy Spall at sea is about the man
himself he and his wife Shane are
dedicated sailing enthusiasts and this
BBC program follows them on their
journeys around the British coast aboard
their Dutch barge the princess Matilda
spall is a delightful guide to the world
of galleys and moorings his passion for
the freedom of life on the seas shining
through at every moment three series
have been produced somewhere at sea back
at sea and all at sea though Spall's
skill and expertise is an enormous part
of the show the foibles of sea life are
part of it as well
the couple infamously became lost in
2011 and had to be guided back to safety
by the authorities of the town of
Sheerness nevertheless Timothy Spall
sails on
spall teamed up with director Mike Lee
for all-or-nothing centered around three
working-class families and the traumas
and victories that define their lives
spawn plays Phil a father and taxi
driver caught in a web of addiction
dead-end jobs and family squabbling that
encompasses roughly a dozen people by
the time the film reaches its end
Spall's character lives a life that
edges on bleak yet he keeps away from
toppling into true despair something
that if anything makes the character
even more heart-rending his performance
has his feet planted firmly in moments
of extreme dysfunction and steadfast
love and honesty but catapults all or
nothing into greatness it's easy to see
why spall is one of Lee's go-to
performers together they find the eye of
the storm that is modern life in the UK
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bells you don't miss a single one
[Music]